pokemon changed the world when it
launched in 1996 in February 27th marks
20 years of Bulbasaur squirtle
charmander than all your favorites the
pokemon company is celebrating with some
new 3ds bundles the bundle features a
3ds decked out with images of Charizard
and Blastoise and a 20th anniversary
logo it also comes pre-installed with
red and blue versions plus a code for a
special Pokemon home menu theme that's
coming to the US but European Pokemon
trainers can grab special to TS bundles
with either red blue or yellow version
pre-installed these are in addition to
the retro looking to the S is coming to
Japan if you don't want to buy a whole
system you can always grab your favorite
version of pokemon from the eShop
they're launching on februari 27 2
there's certainly a lot to celebrate
when it comes to Pokemon the pocket
monsters are even getting their own
super bowl commercial next month so you
can catch them all while catching the
big game and for more Pokemon news and
bad jokes like that you're already in
the right place